the BS out you're not defending yourself
on your carpet bombing civilian
population you're not defending yourself
on in one day you're killing 500
children world is witnessing Israel
slaughtering thousands of children
pushing buttons on Jets and blowing up
entire residential buildings one of my
friends in bokeh he messaged me he said
our family building was bombed 42 of our
family members were killed by Israel in
one night he said our family building
was bombed 42 of our family members were
killed by Israel in one night so when
people say has a right to defend itself
but we see it's not defending itself
it's literally carpet bombing and
killing thousands of civilians